I'm Tom Ford and this is how to direct
your life I think the way to make a
perfect entrance is to do it confidently
and confident by the way doesn't mean
cocky you don't want to walk in the room
being an [ __ ] we're gonna walk in
generally smile stick out your arm and
say hi and never ever use the word
awesome it sort of makes you sound like
you're on Baywatch usually if I'm going
to a party I load my pocket with some
tiny little breath mints because there's
nothing worse than standing chatting
with people especially if they've got
champagne breath I don't drink when I
used to drink it was vodka vodka breath
is much better I actually tried to make
a fragrance with it was vodka and
cigarette breath because I used to find
that quite sexy it didn't really work
when I see people dressed really poorly
I think my god you have got to get a
full-length mirror that sounds terrible
but you have to be brutal with yourself
you have to assess yourself in a kind of
architectural way you have to say Wow
is my head too big for my body because
if it is guess what a shoulder pad will
make your head look smaller supermodels
have tiny heads because it makes them
look tall so we're like the Empire State
Building just tapers up into nothing
everybody has a better side to their
face unfortunately some people's best
side is back some people's best side
from the top some people's best side is
on their back
that's quite loot my best side is facing
the camera right now and it's because
I've been looking at pictures of myself
for 30 years no no one's ever seen it
it's like the Dark Side of the Moon and
not even sure it's there hey done Yeah
right awesome thank you